coup de projecteur à présent sur un
produit atypique que nous pourrions
prochainement retrouver en dégustation
sur toutes les bonnes tables de la
région
le gouda de touraine un sacrilège au
pays du sainte maure et bien pas du tout
puisqu'il s'agit d'une production locale
le lait collecté et transformé dans un
seul et même endroit à son aise dans la
ferme de la famille clippers
les explications de paul boyer voici la
ferme de la famille creepers originaire
des pays bas ils se sont récemment
lancés dans la production d'un good as
locale avec leur savoir-faire
néerlandais avec mon père en fait on a
sélectionné nos bêtes depuis des années
2000 pour avoir un lait de qualité
donc on arrive à avoir des du lait très
riche pour dolce and ce qu'elles sont
plutôt réputé à produire énormément de
l'est mais nous on cherche plutôt la
qualité du lait pour avoir de bons
produits
cela fait maintenant des mois qu'ils
confectionnent leurs premiers fromages
les quatre frères ont relevé le défi
mais c'est l'aîné maurice qui est à
l'origine du projet voici là la
fromagerie qu'on a nous même installé
donc ici j'ai mes premiers fromages que
j'ai fait ce matin donc à cette heure
j'ai cher reçu le lait qui venait tout
de suite de la salle de traite gelé
matures et en cuve durant 45 minutes une
fois mature et maurice transforme
l'équivalent de 400 litres de lait dans
neuf moulin il doit ensuite les
retourner puis les mettre sous presse
une fois pressé le fromage devient
cahiers et bien compact est donc déjà au
bout de bulles
une demi heure le fromage est déjà fort
mais vous pouvez le retenir les mules
sont ensuite entreposés dans une chambre
à température ambiante
surveillez la texture la couleur ou
encore la conservation
c'est un véritable travail d'orfèvre une
fois sur planche
il faut attendre 12 à 18 mois afin
d'avoir un good as de qualité la
dernière étape est la dégustation un
moment que les franges en prennent très
à coeur
on en a coupé un la semaine et le
week-end dernier il je finis nous que la
famille coopers compte bien augmenter
leur production de fromage afin de
continuer à faire vivre leur
savoir-faire néerlandais dans toute la
touraine